it's still early summer but already the
wildfires are burning
this is regos mountain in South Wales
the Flames are proving so hard to
extinguish they're having to Fight Fire
With Fire
specialist teams burn off the vegetation
to create a fire break a tactic more
common in the far hot spots of
California now needed in the UK as the
climate changes
because of the weather conditions
doesn't matter how much water we put in
this fire it will dry out and it will
reignite so our only method here is to
go along control burning according to
the Met Office much of England and parts
of Wales are now at very high risk of
wildfires
while in Scotland firefighters continue
to battle a fire near Inverness North
and South the Heat Wave and lack of rain
have dried out the landscape
it is very early in summer and last year
when we had to fight in London he went
to I believe extreme but that was a lot
later in the year how this year will
build now is quite worrying
the wildfire in Wellington East London
which destroyed several houses is
driving the Tactical rethink drought
provides fires with so much fuel they
spread fast and they're more intense
this shows how difficult it is to
extinguish wildfires of this size now in
the UK the vegetation much of it has
gone but there's enough left for the
flame still to burn although the
firefighters have now moved on following
the fire front
they'll come back and deal with these
later
the Met Office predict UK Summers will
get hotter and drier in the decades
ahead and firefighters are braced for
what's to come
Thomas More Sky News in South Wales